ce soir monsieur jean claude boulay 28
ans professeur d'éducation physique
ceinture noire de judo en homme
tranquille contre saint-malo
contre saint malo saint malo de lille
cité des corsaires patrie de jacques
cartier du ghetto hama et bruxelles
amenait surcouf et dont chateaubriand un
de ses plus célèbres enfin pu dire rien
ne ressemble plus à venise que cette
république malouines par sa religion ses
richesses et sa chevalerie de la mer
saint malo port de commerce port de
pêche bord de guerre a reçu 1000
blessures plus glorieuses unes que les
autres aujourd'hui relever de ses ruines
saint malo fait mentir flaubert au delà
de la ligne est il pas d'amis et la
ligne c'était leur route ou en petits
ruisseaux ses parents sainvet unis
servant et parra mais il n'y a plus de
frontières désormais le grand saint malo
a quitté son rocher
ces anciens remparts ne sont plus que
l'image d'un creuset où bat le coeur
d'une grande cité saint malo bouge
nulle part les mouvements de foule ne
sont plus rapides chacun n'ayant que
quelques pas à faire pour se réunir à
tous à tous contraints bien entendu
monsieur jean claude boulay bonsoir et
surtout merci d'être le premier des
candidats à vous présenter un contre
tous un contre 40 et quelques 1000
habitants voilà qui peut paraître une
gageure et lorsque l'on songe monsieur
boulet que ses habitants sont
probablement décider à tout pour vous
faire échec et bien c'est une périlleuse
entreprise également songeons que si
vous passez cette première étape c'est
une ville de 100000 habitants qui vous
attendra puis en troisième étape trois
ou quatre cent mille pour finir à paris
terme de votre étape mais il ya
évidemment 5 millions d'anciens francs
au bout je pense que le gillot attend
une école de décontraction vous êtes
tout à fait à l'aise mon dieu ça va on
lit d'ailleurs sur cette carte
d'identité d'identité tous ceux que vous
êtes votre curriculum vitae monsieur
goulet malgré tout je m'attends vous
rassurer pour affronter cette périlleuse
entreprise vous disposez quand même 2,3
à tous trois atouts sérieux tout d'abord
les 7 questions très difficiles il faut
bien dire que vous avez minutieusement
et longuement préparée depuis quinze
jours et avec lesquels vous espérez que
les saint malo et ses quarante et
quelques 1000 habitants mais quand ça va
mal ou autres quartiers ah bah voilà et
voilà pour pillage de vaud contre
saint-malo pas de quartier eh bien
monsieur boulet d'ailleurs c'est un peu
la base de notre jeu au fond les esprits
curieux les esprits chercheur au
compilateur peuvent tenter leur chance
il ne s'agit pas d'être un phénomène de
concours pour participer à tous montre
mais pour profiter du deuxième atout il
faut avoir de sérieuses connaissances
parce que ce deuxième atout ce sont les
questions les contres question dite
d'appel qui vous permettront peut-être
d'effacer les points marqués par saint
malo d'ailleurs un rapide coup d'oeil
sur notre tableau va nous permettre de
mieux faire comprendre à nos amis
téléspectateurs le mécanisme du jeu
trois possibilités la première est bien
vous la voyez elle est inscrite au
départ ou marqué avec partait avec sept
points les cette question l'entente
marseille actuellement sur le plateau où
ça crie je pense qu'il se passe quelque
chose là-bas nous irons voir dans
quelques secondes cette question des
parlers s'est déroulée cette fois qu'ils
sont votre capital si d'aventuré saint
malo est une aventure va sûrement
arrivée marque un point alors la lumière
se déplace dans la colonne de la ville
est là bien sûr le point et pour saint
malo mais la question d'appel si vous y
répondez fait glisser ce point dans la
troisième colonne colonnes de
neutralisation est là le point n'est
plus ni à la ville ni à vous c'est une
excellente formule pauvres deuxième
possibilité saint malo répond à l'une de
vos questions le point s'inscrit dans la
colonne de la ville et si vous ne
répondez pas il s'efface bien sûr dans
la vôtre et si vous ne répondez pas à la
question de secours le point reste
définitivement acquis enfin troisième
possibilité saint malo ne répond pas à
vos questions et les points reste dans
votre colonne à la fin il ne s'agit plus
que de faire des comptes extrêmement
facile pour savoir qui de vous deux de
saint malo ou de monsieur boulet
remporte ce match culturel troisième
atout alors là l'on peut dire que c'est
l'inconnue de notre problème l'épée de
damoclès au dessus de votre tête car on
pourrait dire que c'est un contrat tout
ce fameux match qui vient de commencer
et dont vous avez vu les premières
minutes en effet vous allez avoir dans
quelques instants a décidé de prendre un
ou deux points sur les couleurs de
l'olympique de marseille qui défend
âprement vos chances soyez rassurés mais
comme de l'autre côté il ya des amateurs
se marchent toujours très fort quand il
ya des amateurs contre les
professionnels et que ça mal au genou
sur les deux tableaux et veut gagner sur
les deux tableaux si les points que vous
prenez ne sont pas gagnants c'est dire
si l'olympique de marseille ne gagne pas
ils sont retranchés de votre total épée
de damoclès je lis bien arme à deux
tranchants alors décision très grave
maintenant vous avez vu ces premières
minutes vous prenez ce carton sur ce
carton vous inscrivez un ou deux points
à la fin du match nous connaîtrons votre
option marqué ce que vous avez
l'intention c'est une opération tactique
pour vous pensez-y sérieusement 10
secondes pour le faire ce carton vous
lui c'est dans cette enveloppe
cette enveloppe dans cette boîte aux
lettres qui ne sera ouverte que dans
trente et quelques minutes maintenant
voilà ici nous connaîtrons votre option
est maintenant à l'intérieur de cette
boîte à lettres sommeil un ou deux
points qui seront en plus ou en moins
voilà on connaît toutes les données oui
ce n'est pas du tout compliqué d'être un
contre tous et périlleux mais pas
compliqué maintenant monsieur boulet
écoutons attentivement les cette
question avec lesquels vous lancer un
défi à tous a mal aux premières
questions
première question quel personnage se
prétendant colonel américain
suite embarqué à saint malo en janvier
expulsés vers l'angleterre
deuxième question quelles mesures
concernant le recrutement des
fonctionnaires fut proposé en vain en
1831 par un à un loin à l'heure au
gouvernement
troisième question de quel engin
historique
les dijonnais et par suite les français
furent t-il privé dans la nuit du 5 au 6
pluviôse an 3 24 25 janvier 17 195
par suite du mauvais fonctionnement
d'une chaufferette il faut aller vous
chercher tous la quatrième question en
octobre
1791 lafayette reçu un cadeau officiel
qui ne pouvait manquer de lui rappeler
george washington bien que très
indirectement
pourquoi ce à quelques questions boulet
de quel subterfuge usa le maréchal de
saxe en 1749 pour obtenir une sentinelle
à la porte de sa chambre au château de
chambord ce qui était une prérogative au
royal
sixième question pourquoi pour environ
2784 pouvait-on voir à paris force jans
attachés avec des cordes un arbre du
boulevard saint martin au carrefour de
la rue de bondues vous avez beaucoup le
xviiie siècle
enfin 7e question après avoir racheté le
domaine patrimonial du marquis de
belcourt de quels moyens le maréchal
lefebvre reconnaissant usa t-il pour lui
en faire don voilà le fruit des longues
méditations de monsieur boulet et
maintenant eh bien monsieur boulet pour
30 minutes le chronomètre va partir 30
minutes pendant lesquelles vous êtes
véritablement un contre tous voilà c'est
parti eh bien vous pensez eh bien chers
amis téléspectateurs que ces questions
assez torturé il faut bien le dire n'ont
pas été choisis sans être soumis à un
très très sérieux contrôle contrôler et
vérifier même cautionné par nos deux
amis notre duo moves ira andré castelot
et alain decaux que nous sommes
véritablement très heureux de retrouver
et je suis honoré d'ailleurs de vous
accueillir dans cette émission alors je
vous pose une question à votre avis
quelles sont les chances de saint malo
et du candidat dans cette périlleuse
entreprise alain de peau mais écoutez
évidemment quand je regarde les
questions il n'y a pas toutes qu'elles
sont très très difficile alors je ne dis
j'ai tendance à me dire sam à l'autre
même quand il trouvé mais d'autre part
ils sont cinquante mille alors voilà la
question est comment ils étaient 40 pour
viser encore quelques horreurs en
arrondis ou la route à vannes a bondi
pour la rue des licences oui je pense ou
même que 42000 ou cinquante mille
personnes contre un seul c'est très
dangereux alors saint malo est bien
décidée alors je suis un peu inquiet bon
monsieur boulet je ne voudrais pas sur
tous les fervents mauvais moral
avril je dois dire que nous sommes
attachés à ce qu'il n'y aucune
controverse nous avons travaillé à la
bibliothèque respecter d'abord pour être
d'accord l'un avec l'autre important le
disputent aux
questions on a éliminé également les
questions et nous sommes entourés du
maximum de précautions afin qu'il n'y
ait pas de controverse vraiment les
questions sont je crois tout à fait
sérieuse est tout à fait répondant à des
normes n'ont pas joué le souhaite je
vais vous dire pourquoi je le souhaite
parce qu'à part quoi manger l'instant et
j'en suis particulièrement heureux je me
retire car c'est vous qui allez avoir à
dire au cours de ces trente minutes oui
ou non à toutes les réponses qui nous
viennent de saint malo il y en aura de
nombreux surnoms puisque les malouins
sont prévenus depuis quelques heures et
même quelques jours que chaque bonne
réponse rapportera 250 francs 25 mille
anciens francs par le truchement d'un
livret de caisse d'epargne et de
prévoyance
alors bonne chance vous ne quittez pas
la loi et tout de suite nous allons nous
rendre justement sur les trois points de
saint malo nous attendre au point simone
garnier que nous retrouverons et plaisir
au point de michel d'encours au point 3
roger brécourt point simone garnier ici
saint malo à corsair du xviie magnifique
figure de proue qui orne la salle
d'honneur du grand donjon ce grand
donjon édifiant 14 224 par le duc jean 5
est actuellement musées de la ville
c'est ici que se sont donné rendez vous
les tête bien faite et bien pleine de la
ville à savoir monsieur leroux monsieur
leroux qui est représentant de monsieur
le maire premier adjoint entouré de
l'équipe intellectuelle d'intervilles
ici sympathiquement reconstituer ces
monsieurs levitre et monsieur amiable il
y a le conservateur de ce musée qui a
perdu le sourire depuis je dois dire
l'annoncent des questions à monsieur
l'allier il y a le docteur tuloup auteur
de nombreux ouvrages sur saint malo le
directeur des caisses d'epargne et de
prévoyance monsieur brevets notre vieil
ami monsieur lebreton responsable de
l'organisation bref beaucoup de têtes
éminente alors messieurs une question
tout de suite est-ce que vous avez déjà
une réponse à suggérer quelques docteur
pour l'instant pas de réponse encore
messieurs le conservateur non plus
rous harrington mais pour quelle
question s'il vous plaît pour la
première question c'est à dire le
personnage historique qui est expulsé
vers l'angleterre ça vient un dénommé
opus love you et la famille au vieux ça
alors je pense paris vous proposer ça
comme une réponse monsieur la ligue on
se pose naturellement comme réponse
fausse alors de toute façon vous voulez
qu'on peut c'est quelqu'un d'autre ah
oui je crois qu'ils sont défaitistes dès
le départ mais il n'ya pas vous savez
que c'est notabilité il y a aussi
beaucoup d'autres personnes nous sommes
ici ce qu'une cinquantaine même une
soixantaine il y à des mères de famille
il ya des lycéens il y à des professeurs
des employés de mairie un petit peu
toutes les classes cher monsieur est ce
que vous avez une réponse à nous
proposer je règle une question à poser
au sujet de la seconde question
attendait une question à poser je ne
sais pas si vous avez le droit nous
allons voir attendait concernant la
question quelles mesures concernant le
recrutement des fonctionnaires fut
proposé en vain en 1831 par un malouin
au gouvernement alors vraiment du solide
bourse
il s'agit de bourse et bien andré
castelot non à la déco à la noce c'est
une question je voulais qui a l'air
d'être une question sur une question
mais en fait ce qui est si c'est une
réponse à une question allez vous
entendre alors égouts des non usagers
potes pour ça donc bien mais là nous
sommes un petit peu consterné ici et
bien simone garnier simone garnier nous
allons faire le tour des deux autres
points pour mériter son salaire mois de
0,2 michel dans tous les cas
chateaubriand devant l'hôtel de ville il
ya beaucoup de personnes réunies sur
cette place mais hélas guy je n'ai
encore aucune réponse à vous proposer il
y a près de moi monsieur leclerc
représentant des caisses d'epargne et de
prévoyance
il y à monsieur qui représente aussi air
inter qui nous aide dans cette émission
eh bien je crois geek je vais vous
rendre l'antenne parce que je
m'occuperai pour ça vous proposer à
toutes les affaires vont très bien pour
monsieur boulet pour le moment je vois
numéro 3 roger brécourt eh bien nous
sommes ici devant le pavillon du
tourisme à côté du merveilleux bassin
vauban et près de la porte saint vincent
très solide et les malouins malouines
sont venus ici très nombreux avait
beaucoup de chaleur et d'amitié mais
hélas pour l'instant aucune réponse
aucune proposition de réponse alors je
pense que maintenant les malouins
malouines vont venir vers nous avec
beaucoup de précipitation bien que ce
boulet voilà qui n'est pas fait pour
nous surprendre quand on prend comme ça
xi brutaux à des questions aussi
difficiles il faut quand même
s'organiser aller à la bibliothèque
téléphoner compulser quelques ouvrages
j'ai l'impression que le sprint final
sera plus redoutable que le début alors
puisqu'il ne se passe rien j'appelle à
nouveau le point malgré tout qui est le
point d intellectuels où ils peuvent
peut-être jaillir une réponse à vous
simone garnier
je suis là je suis là j'étais entouré
justement d'un groupe qui se pose
quantité de questions et bien pour
l'instant à propos de l'ange à
historique non non il était question de
sous marins et fait venir quand même des
souvenirs quand même des malouins autres
il est bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr
écouter qui envahissent voilà monsieur
ap attendez ça y est un doigt se lève
vous savez on est très nombreux ici on
est venu pour la deuxième question la
deuxième question toujours le
recrutement des fonctionnaires le bâlois
ne serait-il pas chateaubriand
n'alloue deuxième question à la de
pression non ce n'est pas je te brillant
messieurs pire encore il répond si vous
n'avez pas d'autres questions pas
d'autre réponse à proposer monsieur
monsieur le conservateur non
pardon monsieur le conservateur
attention là je fais un petit peu de
course à pied vous m'excusez parce
qu'ils sont un peu partout mais si le
conservateur vis non peut-être brousse
et at-il étudier une affaire politique
que propose le gouvernement il reste que
c'est une qu'une réponse que vous
proposez monsieur oui oppose mais
voulez-vous précisé simone garnier à
laquelle répond cela elle si il s'agit
toujours de la deuxième question lors il
serait tout va bien sur wii voilà c'est
ça à propos du recrutement des
fonctionnaires
mesures repoussé par le gouvernement
monsieur alors je réponds ce brusque oui
il est évident que pour un jeu de ce
genre où tout même des intérêts
importants sont en jeu il faut donner
une réponse complète vous donner un nom
aux yeux c'est pas la question qui
demande évidemment le personnage en
question est très important à trouver si
on le trouve eh bien on a déjà trouvé
une partie certainement de la réponse
enfin il ya autre chose il ya ce qu'il a
proposé ce personnage alors écoutez je
jeu c'est la première fois je crois que
monsieur poulet ne m'en voudra peut-être
pas disons que vous avez donné un nom et
que vous n'avez peut-être pas tort
maintenant voilà mais cela dit c'est la
mesure il nous faut et non pas lui on
voit la mesure que oui on ne vous en
dira pas davantage d'ailleurs nous avons
déjà reçus à côté les saisons nous avons
une autre réponse je crois a proposé à
propos de broussais quatrième question
quatrième question la quatrième question
monsieur qui concerne la fayette
lafayette lafayette lors de sa signature
non monsieur non non et bien alors de
quoi y ont dit non rapidement le point
numéro deux pattes de réponse ah non le
point numéro 2 n'a pas de réponse à vous
proposer mais j'incite tous les mâles
ont elles eu malouines du grand saint
malo nous précisons bien du grand saint
malo à venir à la place chateaubriand
pour apporter des réponses vous qui êtes
devant votre récepteur vous avez
peut-être une bibliothèque alors
dépêchez-vous potasser les livres que
vous avez à votre disposition et vous
voyez ça ce sont des petits livrets de
caisse d'epargne et de prévoyance et un
livret de caisse d'épargné prévoyance à
chaque bonne réponse de 250 francs alors
venez vite nous vous attendons au a3 et
bien pour un toit un jeune homme très
sympathique qui je crois une réponse
pour la première question le colonel
tufin le colonel tufin non non non et
bien nous resterons tellement pas au
fait t'es là vous jouez les professeurs
henri parce que vous avez à faire un
jeune élève non ça n'est pas non non ce
n'est certainement pas ça bon eh bien
nous allons faire un petit tour par
marseille parce que voilà malgré tout
pour l'instant un très bon début pour
monsieur boulet qui a l'air de démarrer
très fort mais est-ce qu'à marseille vos
couleurs sont aussi bien défendu bernard
père
oui oui oui guy lux et bien nous sommes
à une minute environ de la fin de la
première mi temps même si vous le verrez
bien nous allons voir alors que saint
malo bien marque ici marque ici par
l'intermédiaire de françois lent
le deuxième but si vous le voulez bien
on va revenir un peu en arrière avec
l'amp ex pour voir comment les choses se
sont passées à la 11e minute
[Applaudissements]
je dois dire que je dois dire que ça
malo parfait avec un petit avantage
moral car en 1932 en coupe de france
saint malo avait battu marseille et les
amateurs de saint malo font mieux que se
défendre puisque je dois présenter je
vous raconter ce qui s'est passé la 11e
minute saint malo avait ouvert le score
par l'intermédiaire de marcel loncle la
suite d'un corner tiré par le
l'avant-centre ruaudel marcel oncle
avait réussi un très joli tir dans la
lucarne avait donné donc un but c'est à
dire deux points donc pour saint malo
est ici son frère françois longue vous
l'avez vu à l'instant même à marquer un
deuxième but c'est à dire que maintenant
saint malo mène avec 4 points d'avancé
sur marseille qui n'a pas réussi à
marquer un seul but il faut dire que
saint malo fait mieux que se dépense à
l'arrière le jeune amourette marque très
très bien joseph lenoir jose être
l'avant-centre marseillais qui est
toujours très dangereux et ce jeune
garçon ce jeune malouin et valent à la
mi temps est sifflée par l'arbitré ne se
perd tout le ccino qu'à la mi-temps guy
lux saint malo mène par 4 points 0 face
à marseille c'est une surprise et bien
dites moi monsieur goulet avait des
choses qui ne sont pas tout à fait
semblable en rien à saint malo sur le
plan culturel donc actuellement
pratiquement 7.0 mais là vous perdez un
ou deux points tout au moins à la mi
temps alors nous allons tout de suite
refaire le tour des points points oui et
bien guy pendant que les sportifs
gagnent ce qui est bien réconfortant ici
la matière grise travail aussi et
qu'est-ce qui se passe monsieur l'allier
vous avez je crois toujours à l'heure au
sujet de cette deuxième question
concernant broussais concernant le
recrutement des fonctionnaires pour
repousser par le gouvernement alors
quelle réponse monsieur exacte et
précise je pense je ne serai pas prêt si
je pense que bruce et a proposé que les
fonctionnaires avant d'être engagé
passer un examen médical et que cet
examen médical a pu porter sur les
spécialités que bruce a étudié c'est à
dire les études sur les flegme asie ou
simplement sur les questions d'hygiène
est alors d'une hygiène que les
fonctionnaires pourraient peut-être
la fin qui a peut-être choquer le
gouvernement va mais je ne peux pas vous
donner de détails avant de donner la
parole à l'un de gauche qui al air
souriant je voudrais voir le visage du
candidat roger pradines qui lui a l'air
soucieux ce qui va ce à supposer que
nous sommes probablement tout près d'une
bonne réponse alain decaux oui je crois
que nous sommes près d'une bonne réponse
mais enfin la ya un mot un mot essentiel
en ce qui me concerne je ne crois pas
pouvoir donner la réponse bonne car il
nous faut se mouiller maintenant n'est
ce pas il ya en effet nous sommes tout
près mais je crois que le candidat ne
peut qu'être d'accord naturellement mais
j'ai roulé c'est le contraire un
étonnant mais vraiment il faut se
mouiller il ya un dit ce mot alaton au
point numéro un
en somme ce que vous me demandez c'est
qu'elle le
sait peut-être les histoires de maladies
nerveuses
ce qui va aussi fait des études dessus
mais moi je voudrais plutôt sur
l'hygiène
un mot un seul mot enfin on peut dire
que ce n'est pas la sienne non mais bon
là conséquent ni les maladies nerveuses
par conséquent monsieur repos tu as et
si l'on peut dire on y en a probablement
sur vous car vous êtes très près de
marquer le premier point pour saint malo
attention simone garnier d'autres
réponses au point et bien non non non
j'ai alors pas que c'est calme peut-être
peut-être une réponse au point de
monsieur vous avez une solution à nous
proposer la question numéro 1 concernant
le connais de l'américain qui sera
embarquée saint malo le victor hugo non
ce n'est pas ça d'abord ce n'est pas
encore l américain la question et
prétendant qu elles attendent en
prétendant ne veut pas dire qu'il était
qu'elle allait expulser de belgique il a
dû pour passer en angleterre
certainement prendre elle comble il ce
n'est pas la grèce alors je suis désolé
mais ce n'est pas victor usa n'est pas
victor hugo un autre nom à proposer
monsieur non un autre nous enfin pas
pour l'instant pas pour l'aca c'est tout
ce que j'ai à vous proposer merci points
à 3 bien présentement absolument une
proposition mais on me signale que vous
syndicat d'initiative de saint malo
beaucoup d'appels téléphoniques
donne lieu à des controverses parce
qu'il faut venir au point pour donner
les réponses et non pas par téléphone il
nous faut la personne pour être votre
micro beaucoup de gens a fait l'autre
non revenons au point un et bien
attendez long point monsieur le
conservateur vous avez une autre si ce
monsieur simone garnier pouvait le pas
nous tourner le dos nous aurions
peut-être la joie merci monsieur
le problème de la contagion si j'ai un
nom a dit à l'ats le problème la
contagion hélas hélas hélas trois fois
hélas non et alors il ya une autre
réponse proposée pour la question la
première question ce personnage
historique expulsés vers l'angleterre je
reste up l'automne
je suis désolé décidément mais je crois
très bien pour je suis désolé je suis
très content pour les candidats
entendons nous mais on n'est pas partis
de si les malouins je crois de toute
manière l un deux roues qu'il faut quand
même incité les malouins à rester sur
cette question numéro 2 oui parce qu est
une brûlure il brûle il brûle quand
monsieur raphaël tout le tour de la
médecine normalement il devrait tomber
oui guy lux parce que demain nous avons
pas été sans voir les innombrables
volume n'est ce pas qui assure cette
table alors il me semble que si on
fouille dans ses livres produits
notre candidat la wii écoutez pas se
repencher sur broussais toutes les
études que bruce a pu faire mais c'est
ce qu'ils font ils sont déjà quatre ou
cinq avec des volumes des documents
différents et il cherche fiévreusement
par votre réponse mais n'ont pour
l'instant rien du tout rien du tout
alors messieurs bon eh bien je reviens
sur andré castelot et alain decaux parce
que je pense que peut-être ils vont
faire le point alors que nous en sommes
à environ une dizaine de minutes de ce
match d'une demi-heure et je tiens à
préciser nos amis téléspectateurs que au
départ le chronomètre qui était pourtant
le chronomètre qui a servi aux élections
donc il est rodé a fait cinq minutes un
bond de 5 minutes et ça c'est angoissant
d'ailleurs être respectivement se
demande si ça n'a pas existé au moment
de la campagne électorale on aurait tous
mangé 5000 était bien il y aura donc
cinq minutes de plus tout à l'heure à
l'issue du camp de m alors vos
impressions le point et c'est assez
facile à faire puisqu'il n'y a encore
aucune réponse mais il ya une chose
demain petits fours et vêtements
immédiatement souligné c'est que à saint
malo enfin surtout la bibliothèque
maison d'une armada dictionnaire vous
avez vu cette pile de livres alors que
notre candidat ait vraiment un seul
contre tous ce n'est pas seulement seul
contre tous il est seul contre des
bibliothèques
moi je 30 jeux tandis que évidemment les
questions sont difficiles mais on
devrait pouvoir y répondre quand on est
autant d'habitants de saint malo à jouer
oui nous allons assurer quand même les
habitants de saint malo chacune de ces
questions comporte une réponse avec des
références extrêmement sérieuse et il
faudrait peut-être pas se polariser
uniquement comme je crois que nos sages
sont en train de le faire sur bruce et
car si on reprend les unes après les
autres les questions on s'apercevra
qu'elle a moins une ou deux qui sont
même facile disons oui c'est un coup
d'oeil sur le tableau à coup d'oeil sur
le tableau pour rassurer monsieur
monsieur bull est actuellement cette
question poser sept points rien à
glisser dans la colonne de saint malo et
bien à nouveau nous nous rendons au
point un simone garnier oui et bien
toujours au sujet de cette seconde
question qui fait beaucoup travailler
les méninges et si monsieur une réponse
quand je crois que bruxelles avait
proposé de recruter les fonctionnaires
sur l'étude de la conformation de leurs
crampons après les boss du crâne alors
je laisse dire le mot scientifique le
mauvais dicale la phrénologie
alors à vous monsieur voulez vous êtes
d'accord naturellement c'est bien
la phrénologie
il faudrait peut-être guy lux pour les
téléspectateurs rappelé en un mot vous
rassurez vous ce que c'est que la
phrénologie c'est un certain galles ce
pack était un médecin allemand attend
vous pouvez presque un voilà sont
presque de vous voilà prêt selon les
mots l'émietter été beaucoup mieux
c'est pas mais en fait ce galles n'est
ce pas avait vu quand il était étudiant
des petits camarades qui apprenaient par
coeur leur texte lors de leurs leçons le
revers est et il avait pensé que ses
enfants avaient les yeux exorbités et il
en a déduit c'était un esprit logique
que tous les gens qui avaient les yeux à
fleur de tête avec la mémoire et les
partis de là il a élargi son système et
à travers les boss compte nous pouvons
en voir autour du crâne il a cherché
dans chacune de ces boss la localisation
d'un d'une qualité ou d'un défaut alors
justement les dessins par action là et
cette gravure janvion jurés parce que
j'aimerais voir si vous avez des bosses
aux singes en est plein ils nous en
bourse de l'histoire je ne sais pas je
ne sépare de questions mais les postes
qu'on pourrait voir le dessin voilà
c'est le dessin de gauche voyez-vous les
deux boss c'est à dire si vous avez au
dessus des sourcils deux protubérances
et bien d'après monsieur galles d'après
le dr galles ce sont les boss du rire de
la gaieté de l'esprit en revanche là
derrière l'oreille si vous avez une
bosse et la rue et la malfaisance
évidemment tout ça n'est absolument pas
sérieux et je crois qu'il faut surtout
passer très vite son des cornes
je crois qu'il faut vite passer très
vite à pois un peu pour ça va nous
regardons pour l'instant le tableau ce
poids qui est provisoirement inscrit
dans cette colonne car maintenant
monsieur goulet vous pouvez effacer
cette question ce qui serait le compte
d'ailleurs bon saint malo ait eu tant de
mal à le marquer en réponse à une
question d'un père cette question
d'appel nous vient du point à saint malo
avoue simaga oui après que nous ayons
remis un livre de la caisse d'epargne et
de prévoyance
mais je ne sais pas ces messieurs
s'arrangeront ensemble car là vous le
voyez à montrer la voie et le second a
donné la réponse exacte monsieur
lebreton cette question d'appel
maintenant monsieur boulet pouvez vous
nous dire saint malo est dit-on la cité
des grands hommes quel est le seul
d'entre eux qu'il soit inhumé au
panthéon eh bien monsieur goulet vous
avez bien entendu la question vous avez
trente secondes pour répondre et tenter
d'effacer ce point de saint malo quant à
m
la question
vingt secondes
hauser
[Musique]
surcouf saint malo mais sans espoir sans
espoir c'est un surcoût sans espoir
saint malo non monsieur poulet non non
messieurs est vaste et bien je pense que
il nous faut quand même connaître la
réponse est oui c'est terminé vous
pouvez la donner le visage hideux
l'amiral thévenard et surtout venant
vous avez quelque chose à ajouter je
vois là bien thévenard est un amiral qui
peut-être un grand homme on le connaît
peu n'est ce pas et ça prouve qu'ils ont
eux mêmes au panthéon genevois sur dix
mois peuvent pas faire de peine aux
habitants de saint malo j'espère qu'il
m'en voudront pas me refaire un truc ou
même des parents s'il ya des plus grands
hommes que ça au panthéon fabien est
bien passé parce qu'ils ont le tableau
le point de saint malo et confus et
confirmez vous savez que si nous ont
très rapidement du compte nous
apercevons que si à marseille les choses
ont toujours aussi mal actuellement il y
aurait donc un ou deux points de plus
pour saint malo et par conséquent nos
scores devient très équilibré un coup
d'oeil d'ailleurs sur marseille où la mi
temps a dû reprendre la 2ème avoue
bernard pouy la deuxième mi-temps a
repris depuis environ une dizaine de
minutes et c'est un coup franc qui vient
d'être accordé par monsieur perd contre
lille arbitres pour une faute du gardien
de but escale quelle sortie très surface
de réparation le public pourra tester
marcel-oms qui tire mais les marseillais
tu reçois le ballon elles vont pouvoir
se dégager télé si vous voulez bien on
va revenir un peu en arrière car il
s'est passé certaines choses à la 7e
minute de cette deuxième mi temps
et bien la 7e minute puisque nous ne
voyons pas les images marseille a quand
même réussi à marquer un but par son
arrière neuvier la suite d'une très
belle reprise de volée sur un centre
venu de la droite est dressée par les
niches et marcel donc a réduit le score
4 coince à un quart un but vaut un point
pour marseille alors que saint malo
marque deux points pour un but et comme
ils ont marqué deux buts en première mi
temps ils mènent toujours 4 a encore dix
minutes de jeu merci et je regarde le
chronomètre général qui va d'ailleurs
apparaître en surimpression où tout le
monde va pouvoir constater que sur ce
chrono est il ne reste plus que huit
minutes auxquels il faut ajouter 5
minutes j'aimerais bien que roger
pradines nous parce ce chronomètre et
que par conséquent le match a encore 13
minutes à vivre alors pas de chance mais
avec les ampex avec les chronomètres
alors très vite le point voilà il vient
maintenant eh bien voyez-vous la petite
ligne indique qu'il y a simulé + 5 11
minutes avoue le point 1 où il ya
peut-être d'autres réponses oui oui
alors cette fois concernant la troisième
question ce fameux engin historique dont
furent privés les français à la suite de
la panne d'une chaufferette le mauvais
fonctionnement d'une chaufferette qui a
mis le feu à un bateau à vapeur de
jouffroy d'abbans ans
andré castelot non non non ce n'est pas
cela malheureusement une autre réponse
une autre réponse à une autre question
il s'agit maintenant du maréchal de saxe
qui obtint une sentinelle à sa porte
prérogatives royales comment monsieur
une réponse censuré c'est il a revêtu
des habits de femme
à gaza non non pas du tout c'est dommage
d'ailleurs parce que ses pittoresques
d'autre réponse s'il vous plaît vite
vite attendait voilà une jeune femme qui
arrive voilà une jeune femme car il avec
un maxi pardon temps dès
lors ce type était de prévenir par là
les inconvénients funnel de ménage d'un
mélange et crapuleux il supposait que
ceux ci pouvaient se pourvoir ailleurs
c'est la réponse que je ne lisais pas
c'est toujours la même question qui
pardon excusez moi c'est toujours le
maréchal de saxe qui voilà comment
fait-il pour avoir une sentinelle à sa
porte alors il justement il invoqua les
inconvénients funeste d'un mélange
crapules mélange crapules janvier
et loire ont refroidi eh bien je laisse
ma dame actuellement compilé son livre
est très vite nous allons points 2 au
point de madame face à la caméra je vous
en prie vous à l'agression sur mary chan
le relais tout dialogue il a adopté
dans d'autres villes la personne à qui
l'avait acheté le château le marquis
bellecour oui
je crois que là c'est
d'avoir le mark et le marquis de
belcourt fait adopter d'après ce que dit
madame pas vrai
ça
monsieur monsieur vous avez une réponse
à me donner à quelques questions le
cadeau de l'amérique où est la faille et
le canot de l'america lafayette un
paratonnerre un paratonnerre à ta mère
non c'est pas ça n'allait pas
sarko n'est pas tant de naturel
évidemment plus de réponses au point
numéro 2 a pour l'instant non qui met le
numéro 3 03 nous avons un jeune homme
pour la question de bureaux 1 alors
victor hugo non ça te voyant
châteaubriant mais vous d'accord on l'a
déjà dit tout à l'heure il a écouté la
question numéro 4 concernant le cadeau
de la fayette monsieur s'il vous plaît
il s'agit des clés de la bastille les
clés de la bastille et bien alors là
c'est le même problème que tout à
l'heure l'âge non monsieur oui mais j'ai
oublié de vous dire non parce que j'ai
déjà été gentil pour saint-malo tout à
l'heure et le candidat monsieur goulet
vous en voudriez non ce ne sont pas les
clés de la maison quand même dire que ce
monsieur est quand même en train de
brûler quand même sauf apple et son
chauffeur
évidemment il fait des restrictions eh
bien je tiens à préciser pour l'instant
qu'il reste à tous nos amis de saint
malo environ 10 minutes pour essayer de
faire échec qu'à monsieur boulet point
numéro 3 to vous quelques réponses
encore bon le point numéro 5 le numéro 5
s'il vous plaît j'aurai quelque chose à
proposer le maréchal de saxe n'at-il pas
été l'amant d'une future sarine de
russie et peut-être que ce serait servi
de ce plus vilain jeu pour avoir un
garde de titre de roi sa porte avec ac
non non ce n'est pas cela c'est
également comme la streif
6.02 nous revenons dans l'autre sens eh
bien le point numéro 2 nous n'avons pas
de réponse monsieur lebreton est venu en
point numéro 2 ou fait un peu le tour de
tous les pour alto oui je mettrai ça y
chercher la question numéro 7 a effacé
la bibliothèque et bien tout à l'heure
alors comme 1.016 excusez moi guy oui tu
sais moi je crois qu'on a une réponse
est ce que monsieur peut venir s'il vous
plaît vita c'est une demoiselle vip
dépêchez vous et bien sûr nous allons
revenir au point d'aller nous allons
venir d'accord si ici à monsieur tout de
suite monsieur une réponse toujours à
cette même question du maréchal de saxe
est devenu indique que invoqué les
risques d'un attentat ce qu'on a c'est
de le tuer avec à sentir non non c'est
un subterfuge la question le dit bien
n'est ce pas vous l'avez visite et
l'avait noté monsieur la lier à nouveau
pourquoi ne serait-il pas entrer là
chambord en compagnie du roi de france
pourquoi non seulement ce n'est pas seul
à poser des questions à andré castro
c'est une manière de rois de france lui
avait donné chambord mais le roi de
france 2 l'a pas accompagné dans sa
nouvelle résidence
alors à la première question cette fois
le personnage historique embarqué de
saint malo pour l'angleterre puisque ça
ne ferait pas né prince napoléon non
c'est pas grâce un peu les accusant de
napoléon iii non plus
à vous avez encore une quelque chose
derrière la tête monsieur semble-t-il
point numéro 2 le point numéro 2 nous
avons une réponse à la première question
à demoiselle montcalm montcalm non
mademoiselle ce n'est pas mon cas point
numéro 3 numéros 3 je crois qu'il ya une
proposition pour la quatrième question
je propose pour la quatrième question la
montre en or de watchers washington qui
avait une dédicace à jour je washington
et qui aurait été à faire par lui à la
faillite si vous voulez que pensez vous
non non non ce n'est pas la réponse que
propose monsieur goulet d'ailleurs
monsieur goulet nous allons voir son
visage alors que je lui annonce qu'il ne
reste plus que cinq minutes cinq minutes
de jeu le sprint final est entamée et
nous allons connaître le pratiquement
les toutes dernières minutes de
marseille avoue bernard père et bien pas
de changement ici à marseille ça hommen
toujours par quatre points à 1 les
débuts réussis par les frères l'oncle
contre le but réussi par nos vies pour
marseille alors qu'ici joseph vient de
tirer de bugs il faut dire que les
marseillais n'ont pas eu beaucoup de
chance au cours de cette première mi
temps ils ont eux mêmes de cette
deuxième mi temps ils ont mis plusieurs
fois sur des coups de tête de gay niche
du red star qui vient d'être remplacé
par fja vaut la balle de peu à côté mais
les malouins font mieux que se défendre
il joue très très bien très
intelligemment mais il faut dire que le
tournoi de six ne se déroule pas comme
un tournoi normal comme un match à onze
d'abord il n'ya pas de hors jeu c'est le
seul
la seule modification par rapport aux
règles du football et qu' il faut être
de très habitués pour jouer à ce jeu là
en bretagne on pratique beaucoup les
tournois six l'été
puis on perd étant donné que nous vivons
les dernières minutes dans la tornade
culturel forcément prendre aucune minute
à saint malo nous connaîtrons résultat
tout à l'heure en nous rendant à
marseille une dernière fois vinton le
point numéro un
le point numéro 1 est bien ici il y a
une réponse alors toujours pour la
première question le personnage
historique expulsé ce doit être la
rouërie je pense
à la ga salonique lors pas alors une
autre question j'ai une autre réponse je
crois pour toujours
question la voyait les tupan numéro 2
ils pointent numéro de monsieur lebreton
vous arrivez la bibliothèque me
communiquer la réponse suivante pour le
passager de marque qui s'embarque à
saint malo françois d'orléans prince de
joinville fils de louis-philippe engagé
à l'armée de la loire sous le nom de
colonel lui trotte à la déco
vous aurez nous sommes d'accord c'est
tout à fait d'accord avait vraiment
envie
avant monsieur brottes lebreton et bien
vous êtes d'accord monsieur boulet voilà
une deuxième question et nous regardons
très vite ce tableau s'inscrit un
deuxième point pour saint malo un
deuxième point pour saint-malo plus les
points du match sportif voyez que le jeu
n'est pas du tout terminé nous allons
peut-être vivre des minutes présent 60
pour vous monsieur boulet à moins que
vous fassiez immédiatement cette
question vous avez un mot à dire sur
prince de joinville à la hanche
personnage que j'ai ador moi
personnellement il ya une histoire assez
savoureuse à son sujet d'ailleurs
j'aurais ville me laisse une vie de
patachon bonjour la ville dépense
énormément d'argent et un jour la reine
s'aperçoit que la montre qu'elle lui
avait donné il était plus à son bousaidi
mais joinville que tu fais de ta montre
il y voit la montre et bien je laissais
chez ma tante la tente c'était malade
adélaïde la soeur du roi louis philippe
et de là l'expression est passé dans la
langue courante et ma tante je sais le
mont-de-piété passé c'est au
mont-de-piété que genève il est allé
déposer la montre que sa mère lui avait
donné et bien voilà qui détend les
dernières minutes et qui a permis
certainement en train de préparer une
deuxième question appelle à vous le
point 1 mais oui c'est déjà fait la voix
si cette question monsieur monsieur
boulet pouvez vous donner le nom des
bateaux de jacques cartier lors de son
premier voyage au canada y compris la
question parfaitement mokolo m pour 30
secondes je m'élève contre cette crise
alors attention attention même si la
contestation également des randos de
neutraliser le temps pendant
l'observation faite par andré castelot
non il ya une à mon avis ce que je vois
très bien là qu'est la réponse que vous
avez su gérer on a prétendu on a raconté
par fort de quartier avaient baptisé ces
deux bateaux du nom des bateaux de
christophe colomb lapinta et la santa
maria horse est controversé par les
réponses
[Musique]
donc le bon élan et dans un autre
ouvrage il y a le seulement le nom d'un
bateau
le deuxième temps d'appeler la nef tout
simplement par quartier mais je tiens à
vous préciser monsieur voulait que les
réponses aux questions de secours non je
crois qu'ils sont connus de notre
duumvirat et que par conséquent s'ils
refusent la question c'est qu'après
avoir fait des recherches ils ont
exprimé mais je vais poser je vous ai
posé une question à saint malo c'est
évidemment cette réponse là que saint
malo attendait cette réponse est très
con tre dans sa malle à nous nous
trouvons devant un cas notre duo ne vire
à andré castelot alain decaux refuse à
15 août et rebondir que notre ami le
docteur laburthe qui a écrit une
histoire du canada a lui même recherché
cette solution narry n'a pas pu trouver
le nom du bateau par conséquent les a à
saint malo monsieur cette question est
refusé par notre jury dont les décisions
sont équitables sans appel et
probablement nous allons vous demander
de bien vouloir poser une autre question
que celles qui refusaient puisqu'elle ne
comporte pas de référence assez sérieuse
monsieur poulet à saint malo bravo on
applaudit votre sportivité en tous les
cas je vois que vous acceptez cette
décision sans alors maintenant nous
faisons repartir le chronomètre général
puisque nous avons eu ce temps mort ce
temps de neutralisation nous écoutons
cette question d'appel
monsieur boulet comment s'appelait saint
malo pendant la révolution 30 secondes
chrono m pendant la révolution je ne me
trompe pas la plupart des une des villes
qui commençait par au sein ont vu le
saint supprimés il restait donc malo et
je crois qu'on a ajouté port devant le
nez pour malo je fais la réponse que je
connais je ne sais pas s'il est valable
eh bien nous allons de savoir tout de
suite on nous rendre à saint malo ce que
la question d'appel est satisfaisante la
réponse très raide dingue c'est plus
exact elle vient bravo monsieur mal au
bras vous bien voyez que la question
apple a magnifiquement joué pour vous
vous effacer le point nous jetons un
coup d'oeil sur le tableau et nous
apercevons que vous avez neutraliser
cette réponse donc actuellement vous en
est toujours à 5.1 points du côté de
saint malo un point neutraliser et je
pense elle a malheureusement pour vous
des points de perdus sur le terrain de
football très vite retour des trois
points les trois derniers tours poids 1
c'est fini c'est le dernier
bien jeu est ce que vous avez compris la
radio des déchets traités docteur de
maraîchage déjà c'était prétendants à
bayard il serait parti par une même
d'une fille et il aurait mis une
sentinelle à ta porte pour faire quoi qu
il était encore chez lui ça c'est très
xviiie siècle comme réponse mais ce
n'est pas ça et passa point numéro 2
vous savez une réponse à quelques
questions sur la question sur la feuille
alors je vous écoute il s'agit d'une
pirate investi d'une pire à la bastide
c'est à dire on aurait donné regarder la
caméra s'il vous plaît là bas alors
qu'on aurait donné une pire équipe à la
bastille on a tenu bien la bastille dans
l'est libyen a failli 1 cela répond ça
n'est pas la réponse paraît enfin point
numéro 3 bien opprimés d'euros 3 on nous
propose une
réponse à la question numéro 5
concernant le maréchal de saxe bon je
pense que le maréchal de saxe aurait
apposé sur sa porte une décoration royal
décerné par le roi non ce n'est pas cela
et au moment où wardrecques à ce l'on
disait ça n'est pas cela la sonnette
retentit c'est marquant définitivement
le temps imparti à saint malo pour
essayer de répondre aux sept questions
de monsieur boulet qui respire qu'ils y
voient là une première étape de franchie
et bien le résultat je pense du match de
marseille n'a qu'une importance relative
car très rapidement nous avons pu voir
que le score était favorable de toute
manière mais néanmoins qui laisse au
score avoue bernard père pour les
dernières secondes eh bien le score
s'est aggravée puisque il y a à peine
trois minutes l'avant-centre ruaudel sur
une très belle passe de winne mans a
marqué un nouveau but pour saint malo si
bien que saint malo finalement bat
marseille 6.1 c'est dire que scratch
c'est à dire sans le handicap il battait
quand même marseille 3 heures c'est une
surprise d'ailleurs je crois que vous
nous montrer des images du match non je
voyais les images sauter non l'ex ne
fonctionne pas si si l'apec fonctionne
là c'est un corner qui va être tiré par
joseph
et qui ne donne rien car les marseillais
n'ont pas marqué de but au cours de ces
dernières minutes de la deuxième mi
temps ils ont marqué en tout et pour
tout un seul but qui a été
par nos vies si c'est arte les à qui
s'en va chercher le ballon je crois que
c'est sur cette action que le but
marseillais a été marqué voici arthélyse
a
heart and les dégagements et une emprise
de novices y voyait la balle au fond
malgré
jean-cholle l'excellent gardien de nuit
malouin qui n'a rien à se reprocher sur
ce but du reste jolie donc score final 6
à 1 pour
mercy un mal bien si marseille merci
l'olympique de marseille merci et bravo
sam alors regardons maintenant notre
tableau récapitulatif monsieur boulet
qui sanctionne votre victoire sur le
plan culturel par cinq points à 1 et sur
le plan sportif non simplement regardé
par acquis de conscience qu'elle était
l'option que vous aviez prise un très
beau chiffre d'ailleurs très artiste ce
que nous montre la caméra je ne sais pas
d'ailleurs si on le voit d'ailleurs vous
l'aviez grise et c'était le chiffre 1
vous aviez été prudent vous n'aviez pas
tellement confiance apparemment pas du
tout qui a comme c'est curieux pourtant
les professionnels de marseille sont en
très grande forme en ce moment
les amateurs dont les professionnels
font toujours des experts c'est vous
perdez un point donc regardons ce
tableau définitive score définitif
regardez en bas tout à fait en bas vous
gagnez monsieur par 5 points à 2 et bien
la porte de nîmes vous est ouverte nîmes
ville de 100000 les quelques habitants
qui sera votre deuxième étape où j'ai
l'impression que les nîmois maintenant
instruit de la manière dont il faut s'y
prendre seront infiniment redoutable
vous gagnez en tous les cas ce soir cinq
cent mille anciens francs vous pouvez
partir avec ou revenir pour tenter 1
millions d'anciens francs en deuxième
étape mais en abandonnant tout de ce que
vous avez gagné en première alors
rassurez vous pour réfléchir nous allons
maintenant nous tourner vers andré
castelot et alain de coûts qui vont nous
donner les réponses très rapidement aux
questions qui n'ont pas reçus on
pourrait commencer par la question
numéro 3 l'engin l'engin historique et
historique est bien l'enjeu historique
c'est la berline qui a servi à louis
saez et la famille royale le quitter
paris et ils ont été arrêté à varennes
et la berline à son retour a servi de
diligence sur la route de dijon jusqu'au
jour comme nous le disions dans la
question jusqu'au jour où la berline à
la suite du feu pris par une
chaufferette la berline a pris feu et a
disparu ça c'est donc la réponse pour la
berline mais vous avez une question
numéro cargaison numéro 4 c'était la
question relative aux liens entre
washington et la fayette et bien on a
frôlé deux fois on a prononcé le mot de
bastille mais on n'a pas dit l'objet
c'est que on l'avait donné à la faille
est une épée dans la lame était faite
d'un métal qui venait des verrous de la
bastille on l'a dit pierre on a dit vue
qu'est ce qu'on a dit d'autre sur les
clés de la bastille et c'était bien les
verrous si on l'avait dit verrou c'était
beau 91 4 et vous voici ce monsieur
voulait bravo encore une autre réponse
c'est bien le maréchal de saxe qui a
fait couler beaucoup de paroles tout à
l'heure eh bien le maréchal de saxe
avait donc là de prérogatives royales
lorsqu'il est arrivé à chambord entre
2,9 et un régime en douceur son ancien
régime banques le roi lui avait autorisé
à amener avec lui mais il y avait une
chose qui n'avait pas pu obtenir et il y
tenait beaucoup c'est d'abord une
tontine sentinelles à la porte de sa
chambre et d'un privilège royal alors il
avait trouvé l'idée de mettre simplement
deux mots sur ça il avait mis caisse
militaire l'émile deux mots sur la porte
caisse militaire et grâce à cela pour
protéger cette caisse il avait pu mettre
une sentinelle devant sa porte et tout
enlever si vous voulez avoir trouvé tout
cela est voir assez bien enfin la
quatrième de la
cemac est quatrième et bien c'est cet
arbre n'est ce pas cet art dont monsieur
boulet avait parlé cet arbre auquel on
s'attache et au carrefour de la rue de
bondy eh bien c'était un arbre qui avait
été magnétisés par le fameux messmer le
roi du magnétisme au xviiie siècle cet
allemand qui était arrivé de vienne avec
un bac es et qui avait fait courir tout
paris qui avait mis le magnétisme à la
mode il est d'ailleurs parti quelques
années plus tard en oubliant son baquet
mais en emportant l'équivalent d'un demi
milliard de nos francs le magnétisme
rapporte qu'elle vient canton maréchal
le faire puisque c'est la dernière
question il aimait beaucoup monsieur
lebel cours qui avait été son chef
autrefois et monsieur delecourt l'avait
tellement protégés qu'ils avaient été
promis lorsque bill côté partie en
immigration de lui faire un grand
plaisir un jour et de lui offrir le
château et lui offert son château en
mettant les titres de propriété dans sa
vie' giberne de sergent qu'il avait
toujours conservé il l'attendît au
monsieur de courant d en garder là comme
moi j'ai toujours gardé d'ailleurs cette
histoire me rappelle une autre qui est
un peu voisine lorsque napoléon a nommé
le maréchal lefebvre duc de d'annecy qui
l'a d'abord accusant bonjour monsieur le
duc et les fèves s'est imaginé qu'on se
moquait de lui que l'empereur se moquer
de lui il en prend lui a tendu un paquet
faisant monsieur le maréchal puisque
vous venez de prendre d'annecy qu'il est
normal que la ville d'annecy qui fasse
un cadeau voici du chocolat de dan sic
d'âge du que le nouveau duc a mis le
paquet dans sa poche est rentré chez lui
l'a ouvert il y avait 500 mille francs
est depuis dans la grande armée
lorsqu'on parlait d'argent on appelait
l'argent c'était un synonyme le chocolat
de dante sica tu reçu ta paye on ne fait
pas ça on dit ah tu reçu ton cheval
d'annecy merci andré castelot je ne suis
pas napoléon monsieur mai vous remet un
chocolat d'un titre puisque je vous
remets 500 mille francs à moins que vous
préfériez doubler la mise et revenir
dans quinze jours affronter nîmes mais
je préfère deux chocolats des
chocolats de danzig eh bien je pense que
tous vos enfants vont être nombreux non
pas avec madame
boulet mais avec avec toute votre classe
combien avez-vous d'élèves environ 600
soit fait en train d'applaudir en ce
moment monsieur bull est tout heureux de
le retrouver dans quinze jours et
surtout tous ces petits polio dont vous
vous occupez avec tant de gentillesse et
en tendresse et gagne pour ça vous nous
êtes infiniment sympathique nous
retrouverons donc monsieur boulet dans
quinze jours face à nîmes ainsi se
termine notre émission merci à saint
malo merci à tous les malouins ce n'est
pas une défaite c'est très honorable
c'était quand même difficile d'essuyer
les plâtres surtout comme ça avec des
questions aussi difficiles merci à
l'olympique de marseille bravo à lui à
saint malo merci à la castelot merci à
non cash avec
c'est quand même terrible merci monsieur
voulait amis téléspectateurs merci votre
attention bonsoir
[Musique]